back in this country the United States
now has more than 85,000 coronavirus
cases now that is the most in the world
among those helping to battle the
pandemic our Facebook CEO Mark
Zuckerberg and his wife dr. Priscilla
Chan in an exclusive interview
Zuckerberg told us about his company's
role in the fight this morning the
couple is also announcing that their
charitable group the Chan Zuckerberg
initiative is partnering with the Bill
and Melinda Gates Foundation on possible
treatments you know when we interviewed
you a few months ago about CGI one of
the things you said that stood out to me
guys was what we'd like to do is
eliminate all disease in our children's
lifetime boy you certainly couldn't have
seen anything like this coming what are
you doing specifically to advance that
I'm really proud to share that CGI is
going to be joining Gates and others to
put together something that calling the
therapeutics accelerator to fight corona
virus they're going to fund a group to
screen all the drugs that we know have
potential effects against corona virus
figuring out drugs is always expensive
but philanthropy can do a role in
kick-starting this so we're gonna be
contributing twenty five million dollars
with Gates and others to be able to get
this started quickly and now part of the
idea here is that often a drug can be
helpful against multiple diseases so you
can basically take all those drugs that
have already been screened as safe and
test them to see if they might also have
a positive impact for either preventing
the corona virus or reducing the
symptoms and making it less damaging
mark I look at Facebook that company
you've got something like 45,000 people
who are now working at home please tell
me the challenges of working with that
we basically have asked everyone to stay
home and even if you can't practically
do your work from home we're gonna make
sure that you get paid in full for your
time through this period and I hope that
that can set an example for some of the
other companies out there but mark you
don't know how long this period is going
to be that's true but there are a lot of
companies that I think can afford to
take care of their people and I think we
have a responsibility to do that
Facebook usage is you know it's off the
charts but your ad revenue is down what
you're talking about in the billions of
dollars are you rethinking your business
model because of that no nothing drastic
like that and look yes we have an
advertising business I do think it will
be hit we're fortunate enough to be a
larger company that that has a
meaningful cash reserve and I think
we'll be able to weather this and do
okay my priorities right now are making
sure that we take care of our community
I'm confident we'll get through this if
we do the right thing do you see this as
an opportunity to rebuild the brand I
know certainly over the last few years a
lot of people have had questions about
whether we've been proactive enough and
handling different situations and I
think given that history we it's
especially important for us to show that
we can be proactive and handling this
well I'm very proud about how our teams
around the world have pulled together to
support people getting accurate
information fighting misinformation
supporting small businesses and their
recovery making sure that important
social and communication services that
people rely on to keep in touch with the
people they love stay stable and running
Marc talk about bringing people together
Dee nicest party the other night on
Instagram
[Music]
got so excited when he heard you were in
the room it about that was very nice
that it was I mean look it is really
inspiring to see how people are finding
ways to come together and support each
other even when we can't be together in
person well you all you two certainly
didn't need a pandemic to bring you
closer together but has this led to a
more melding of your two lives together
the only adult I can talk to in person
so pretty pretty solid one you know I
would have probably been a little warmer
but you know I I would have said you're
my favorite person and if I had to be
locked up with anyone it would be you
and tell me how you get through it are
you afraid are you optimistic are you
hopeful because I think we're living in
a time where a lot of people are you
know to put it bluntly just terrified
there are so many people working
together on this and I think there are
so many people who are reaching out and
caring for each other in a way that is
beautiful and there there's already
people who have lost their lives and are
putting so much into this I can see
Priscilla this is making you emotional
I'm curious about why I it's because I
just I feel so heartened by all the
people that are on the front lines
taking care of us and it's not just the
doctors it's the people in the grocery
stores the mail delivery person to make
sure we have what we need and so the
everyday bravery and hard work and
people in the scientists who I'm getting
emails constantly about people who want
to contribute so I just altogether that
has to mean something
yeah Priscilla Chan is a pediatrician by
training and sees patients and she said
sometimes she actually wonders if she
should come to New York and pitch in but
she knows listen she has a lot of work
to do in San Francisco they've got two
young daughters too so everybody's at
home trying to figure it out and you
know she thinks that it'll be like
Katrina where we have to have a
rebuilding plan we know that's to come
we're not thinking about that now but
they both have great confidence and
great faith and we keep saying it over
and over again that we're
this together and that we will get
through this but going through it is
very daunting yeah and a great effort
there to support the search for
treatments yes yes they're putting a lot
of money at that you know her medical
background his tech background it's a
perfect combination of the two